As you can see from Liz's story,
programming skills can impact anyone.
As for my story, I became
interested in programming because I
thought it would enhance my
roles as a teacher and a dancer.
But eventually, I came to a crossroads.
I wasn't sure whether I wanted to
pursue a career as a programmer or
stay a teacher, so I decided to do both.
You may be at a similar
point in your journey.
The next few lessons will explore
four specific careers within
the technology industry.
There are certainly more paths
within the programming world,
and you may even decide to
go in a different direction.
In any case, every industry
is affected by technology.
By having a better understanding of
what goes into computer programmers,
you can shape the tools
that impact the world.
Let's follow Anthony on his journey
through the world of programming.